jean
christophe picard bonsoir nous [musique]
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle sinécure view vous reçoit dans
le cadre de votre association anti
comment est ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement je
m'appelle jean christophe picard j'ai 46
ans j'habite nice de profession je suis
attaché principal territorial et je suis
président
d'anticorps depuis 2015 vous quel type
de formation moi j'ai fait droit et
sciences po je
sais c'est venu comme ça antico ensuite
par la suite c'est pourquoi c'est un
ras-le-bol c'est ça vous a pris aux
tripes vous appelle le chevalier blanc
de l'éthique norme c'est un peu exagéré
en fait moi quand on habite nice vous
savez on est sensibilisé par les
affaires de corruption très tôt et
[rires]
lorsque j'ai été étudiant dont j'étais
un petit peu choqué par ce qui par ce
qui se passait dans ma ville et j'avais
créé un club de réflexion aussi appelé
le club éthique et politique qui visait
à réhabiliter la politique par les tic
c'est en 2000 c'était deux ans avant tic
ans et j'ai dans ce cadre là j'ai
rencontré deux ans après une jeune femme
qui s'appelait séverine tessier et qui
m'a dit viens avec nous on va créer une
association d'envergure nationale qu'on
va appeler anticorps voilà donc on a
créé anti
2002 en 2006 j'ai créé le premier groupe
local qui s'appelait anticorps 06 parce
qu'on avait quand même la conviction que
la corruption s'était pas que des
grandes affaires nationales qui avait
aussi la corruption locale surtout même
dans les petits villages de la
corruption qui passe un peu en dessous
des radars qui n'intéresse pas les
médias et parfois qui n'intéressent pas
non plus beaucoup de préfet parce que
c'est les petites sommes mais bon une de
rien ça peut vite chiffrés dans un petit
village quand un terrain devient
constructible du jour au lendemain quand
c'est sur la côte d'azur c'est quand
même des gros enjeux donc [grognement]
j'ai créé donc en 2006 le premier groupe
local et maintenant anticorps à 80
groupes locaux et on est c'est une des
forces d'anticorps c'est cette proximité
cette vigilance y compris dans des
petites affaires parce que encore une
fois il ya beaucoup de problèmes dans au
niveau local vous gagnez combien
anticorps est en vous or manticore 0 en
tant que fonctionnaire territorial à peu
près un peu moins de 3000 euros par mois
net wind est oui oui on dit quand vous
payez pas vous êtes défrayer vous avez
un budget de fonctionnement de combien
vous avez des appels aux dons un tipi
une cagnotte comme les gens vous donnent
de l'argent alors anticor a très peu de
moyens parce qu'on a on a fait le pari
de refuser toute subvention pour rester
indépendant donc c'est un luxe d'être
indépendant mais évidemment on a très
peu de moyens puisque on vit de nos
cotisations hainaut dont on a
aujourd'hui à peu près un budget de 110
100 à 1000 euros qui
sert beaucoup au fait même la plupart de
la plupart des fonds servent à payer des
frais d'avocat parce que cela s'élève et
ça chiffre très vite moi en tant que
président donc je suis pas payé je suis
rembourser de mes frais quand je me
déplace à paris des frais de de train
d'avion ou d'hôtel par exemple les frais
de bouche sont pris à ma charge ils sont
à ma charge donc je ne coûte pas très
cher voilà donc un petit peu comment
fonctionne l'association encore une fois
on a très très peu de moyens donc oui on
peut nous aider en adhérent ou en
faisant un don l'argent est bien utilisé
vous êtes sur quel type de dossier en ce
moment alors
on est on a sorti a pas très longtemps
dossiers corses important qui nous
permet d'aborder la question du contrôle
les subventions au niveau européen sur
l'agriculture c'est ça c'est ça parce
qu'on a on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait
des
détournements potentiel là bas parce
qu'il y avait subventions attribuées
pour favoriser les exploitations
agricoles et on s'aperçoit que certains
ont abusé du dispositif en déclarant des
terrains qui sont pas eux on déclarant
des déchets
tels qu'ils n'existent pas et donc là on
a estimé sur quatre ans une fraude de 36
millions une fraude massive dire qu'il
ya évidemment pas que quelques-uns c'est
vraiment massif donc c'est intéressant
parce que dans le cadre des élections
européennes ça va permettre un peu
d'aborder la question des contrôles les
subventions européennes qui
parce que c'est de l'argent public même
si c'est l'argent européen
et puis on est aussi sûr
sur la sphère alstom aussi que sur
laquelle on a essayé d'insister un petit
peu qu'est ce que c'est qu'un stop alors
c'est une problématique intéressante
pour anticorps parce qu'en fait l'état à
renoncer si vous voulez a levé une
option d'achat qui lui aurait permis
mécaniquement gagné 350 millions
puisqu'en fait il y avait une système de
bonus lukacs pas ces détails et en
refusant de lever l'option d'achat donc
on perd 350 millions donc nous on a
porté plainte pour détournement de biens
publics par négligence c'est sur ce
motif lac christine lagarde avait été
condamné dans l'affairé tapie donc ça me
semble intéressant parce que ça
permettrait de responsabiliser les
hommes politiques en leur disant mais si
vous gérez pas bien si vous prenez les
mauvaises décisions soient ou alors même
c'est quand vous ne prenez pas de
décision mais que ça nous porte
préjudice à porte préjudice à l'argent
public et à l'état vous pourrez vous
retrouver devant un tribunal et rendre
des comptes donc ça me semble très
intéressant de
de développer cette jurisprudence moyens
dans
le code pénal cette infraction est prévu
le détournement de biens publics par
négligence on essaie de faire vis est
celle du respect ans pour un peu
responsabiliser les boutiques encore une
fois nous moi j'ai quand même le
sentiment que les lui donne c'est un
petit peu ce qu'il veut de l'argent et
ils sont fichés après nous on se
retrouve des factures exorbitantes et
moi ça me ça m'attriste voilà quand
[soupir]
on parle de justice fiscale si vous fait
penser à quoi et bien justement il y en
a pas de justice fiscale c'est le
problème l'impôt en soi n'est pas pas
critiquable c'est un moyen de répartir
les richesses plutôt bien mais lorsqu'il
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de justice fiscale
lorsque certains ne payent pas l'impôt
parce qu'ils sont trop riches pour payer
des impôts ce qui est quand même assez
c'est fougères à limite que quelqu'un
soit trop pauvres pour payer d'impôts je
l'entends et quand quelqu'un arrive à ne
pas payer d'impôts par la fraude ou
l'optimisation
fiscale en fait l'optimisation fiscale
c'est la fraude toléré donc ça n'est pas
non plus acceptable
là ça pose un problème puisque au final
il n'y a plus qu'une toute petite partie
de la population qui va qui va payer des
impôts et donc du coup ils vont payer
pour tout le monde forcément l'impôt est
mal ressenti par ce que il est trop
élevé et il ya normalement il vers une
fois aujourd'hui on estime quand même la
fraude fiscale et l'optimisation fiscale
chaque année le coup la fraude fiscale
et l'optimisation fiscale est estimé
entre 80 et 100 milliards sachant que
pour la france déficit qui est un peu un
peu moins de 100 milliards on comprenait
qu'en fait le déficit la france est tout
simplement notre incapacité à lutter
contre la fraude et et l'optimisation
fiscale à ce qu'est ce qui fait
réfléchir si on arrivait à faire rentrer
l'argent qui devrait normalement rentrer
on serait en excédent fait rêver quand
même 100 milliards ça fait combien de
millions sans
me fier c'est vrai qu'on est sur des
sommes ça fait 100
milliards ça fait cent mille
millions voilà millions
qu'on produit gilet jaune oui
mais nous mêmes on était gilet jaune
avant que saguenay cirque ont aussi on
trouve que c'est pas normal de payer
autant d'impôts d'avoir des services
publics d'eau si piètre
qualité ou d'avoir des prestations
sociales aussi basse parce qu'encore une
fois l'argent ne rentre pas comme il
devrait rentrer c'est ça le le vrai
problème donc on a toujours dit que
c'était c'est une situation qui ne
pouvait pas durer à partir du moment où
on va pas chercher l'argent là où il
devrait là où il est là où devrait
rentrer c'est bon ça peut pas tenir
longtemps comment est ce que vous allez
ici de chercher à comprendre la
psychologie de cette peur classe qui
refusent de payer un coût qui fait du
window dressing qui fait de l'évasion
fiscale parce que ce que pour vous vous
avez côtoyé ces gens là est ce que
non j'ai pas côtoyer ces gens là mais je
cherche pas à les comprendre il ya des
règles on les applique vous savez
lorsqu'on fait une loi on ne dit pas aux
baiana qui veut pas le respecter les
pauvres ont alors demandé pourquoi non
soit on la fait pas la loi si on veut
pas que les gens le respectent soit
quand on l'a fait on applique et je ne
comprend pas le manque d'entrain
d'appliquer les lois fiscales dans le
programmes des manuels macron il n'y
avait pas grand chose sur la fraude
fiscale il y avait on va renforcer les
sanctions contre les fraudeurs fiscaux
l'ouest pas un programme très très
détaillés alors que c'est un problème
majeur la fraude fiscale c'est des
sommes colossales on pourrait aussi
parler de la corruption qu'un coup aussi
entendu la corruption est ce que
[raclement de gorge] vous pensez que
notre note système judiciaire est
sous-dimensionné
sous-équipés à dessein en
tout cas il est sous dimensionné vous
avez raison parquet national financier
qui est le super parquet de la france il
ya 18 magistrats brigade
nationale de lutte contre la corruption
qui sont 28-28 inspecteurs là j'ai vu
que depuis 2010 il y avait 3000 sans
vérificateur fiscaux en moins donc ça
c'est ce sont les gens qui sont chargés
justement de vérifier les déclarations
fiscales donc très étonnant le contrôle
de légalité hausse il a baissé d'un
tiers en cinq ans c'est très étonnant
que alors même qu'on constate de plus en
plus d'abus est sûre sur des sommes
considérables
on baisse les fonctionnaires les agents
chargés de contrôler tout ça très
étonnant parce que on se doute bien que
si on recrute dix magistrats de plus a
coûté très cher par rapport à la somme
en l'autre une vire ses succès
considérable alors est ce que c'est une
volonté sans doute parce que lorsqu'il
ya une volonté politique on peut on peut
recruter dix fonctionnaires de plus
partie dysfonctionnelle de plus par là
sans doute qu'il ya une mais
peut-être qu'il ya un déni parce que par
exemple en france qui est très étonnant
c'est qu'il ya pas de chiffres officiels
les chiffres de l'estimation la
fraudeuse optimisation fiscale ce sont
des chiffres donnés par un syndicat qui
s'appelle solidaire finances publiques
et donc c'est un syndicat qui capte bien
fait qu'elle fait un très bon travail
mais donc on n'y a pas de chiffres
officiels du coup la corruption et la
fraude fiscales donc on est un peu dans
le déni cirque ont ni un phénomène
important et on est même on ne donne pas
même des chiffres officiels donc
monsieur darmana indiquent que d'ici un
an doré une estimation officielle enfin
du coup la fraude fiscale ce qui nous
permettra d'avoir au moins une base de
travail mais c'est quand même très
étonnant qu'on n'ait pas de
sainte-thérèse pas officiellement qu on
n'est pas aidés des outils de mesure
officielle de ces fléaux qui sont sur
dix qui porte sur des dizaines des
centaines de milliards une
petite question d'internet la corruption
était inhérente au capitalisme non
[raclement de gorge]
et la corruption est inhérente partout
dans tous les systèmes à partir du
moment où l'on contrôle pas au bout d'un
an ça s'installe donc il faut contrôler
il faut sanctionner voilà du moment où
il ya de contrôles et des sanctions la
corruption et diminue c'est ce qui se
passe dans les pays scandinaves où il ya
une forte transparence et comme par
hasard très faible corruption et comme
par hasard ce sont des pays où où les
gens sentent le plus heureux hussein
chaque année il ya un indice du bonheur
et les pays les plus heureux sont les
pays scandinaves donc où le bouton le
bouton peut-être enfin les pays
scandinaves où comme par hasard ya peu
de corruption est très forte
transparence puis une très bonne
répartition des richesses les gens se
sentent très heureux donc je pense que
je pense que c'est lié que c'est pas une
coïncidence parce que effectivement
quand l'argent est bien utilisé on est
plus content on a un des meilleurs
services publics ont à en payer moins
d'impôts on l'a donc il ya des cercles
vertueux qui s'enclenche et où les gens
sont plus satisfaits emmanuel macron
vous en pensez-quoi dans sa capacité à
endiguer ce phénomène de corruption et
d'évasion fiscale alors si vous allez y
la chauffe soufflé le chaud et le froid
parce que il a nommé un premier ministre
qui avait voté contre les lois de
transparence on était un petit peu
contrarié et puis il annonce que la
première loi ça va être une loi de
moralisation qu'on dit souhaite et puis
en plus nous nous ou auditionne j'ai été
auditionnée par monsieur bayrou donc on
a pu présenter nos idées nos mesures
puis au final d'une loi qui est quand
même très décevante qui part qui
contient des avancées phocéen des niamey
qui sont pas du tout à la mesure de
l'enjeu donc voilà on était un petit peu
déçue je crois qu'il y avait quand même
beaucoup de choses à faire on
on a un petit peu on a un petit peu raté
l'occasion d'autant plus qu'il y avait
beaucoup de nouvelles têtes donc on
pensait que les nouveaux députés
allaient être un peu plus audacieux que
les autres et puis on était un peu
étonné par an que les députés en marche
votre compte la suppression du bureau de
bercy c'est quand même très étonnant en
direction des jeunes députés qui arrive
je pense à pelé nous lever ou bercy mais
le verrou de bercy ça et c'est très
particulier puisque normalement on
savait qu'il ya la séparation des
pouvoirs donc juste ita côté exécutif
les vers de bercy c'est la capacité en
fait on ne peut pas poursuivre en
fraudeur fiscal sans l'autorisation du
ministre des finances donc ce qu'on
appelle le verbe bercy c'est une sorte
de veto c'est lui qui peut autoriser les
poursuites contre un fraudeur fiscal
donc ce verrou de bercy les sénateurs à
l'époque de la loi de mobilisation a été
les sénateurs avaient supprimé niveau de
bercy et les députés rpt marchon sont
posés à ça cette suppression monde alors
depuis il ya eu les routes bercy a été
un peu desserré
c'est à dire que maintenant il ya quand
même il
ya quand même il ne s'applique pas à
partir d'une certaine somme de à partir
de cent mille euros de fraudes il
s'implique plus mais enfin il existe
toujours ce qui pose un problème s'ils
posent beaucoup de problèmes déjà en
termes de séparation des pouvoirs c'est
très curieux finalement que l'exécutif
puisse s'opposer des poursuites
judiciaires mes grands quand le ministre
de la justice des finances appelle
cahuzac ouverte on comprend bien que
c'est un peu un peu embêtant qui puisse
s'opposer aux poursuites fiscales séjour
le goût lui-même frauder c'est pas
terrible mais woerth qui était à la fois
faut se rappeler quand même les choses
il était à la fois milieu du budget il
était à la fois trésorier du parti au
pouvoir ça pose un peu des problèmes
pendant deux ans ça a duré on comprend
bien que c'est un peu problématique
celui qui peut autoriser des poursuites
fiscales soit en même temps celui qui va
recevoir les dons de riches de laisser
le proverbe plus c'est gros plus ça
passe oui c'est toujours pas interdits
en tout cas ce type de cumul petite
question internet que pense-t-il du
statut actuel des lanceurs d'alerté
alors il ya beaucoup à dire nous mêmes
on a été auditionné dans le cadre de la
loi sapin de et on a on a pu faire
avancer un peu la définition on était
assez content d'ailleurs sert pas à
grand chose souvent quand on est
auditionné mais là on avait réussi parce
qu'au début la définition du lanceur d
alerte c'était uniquement celui qui
dénonçait des affaires de corruption or
il faut savoir qu'un lanceur d alerte
aujourd'hui tout ce qu'on connaît ce
sont ceux qui ont dénoncé soit des
affaires de fraude fiscale soit des
atteintes graves à l'intérêt général
comme par exemple la sphère luksic
antoine deltour s'était il n'a pas
dénoncé des délits ou des crimes
dénoncés vraiment un scandale qui
n'étaient pas interdits mais qui était
une atteinte grave l'intérêt général
donc on a réussi à élargir la définition
donc aujourd'hui à définition elle est
bonne mais le dispositif mis en place
est extrêmement compliqué
on va même incompréhensible puisque on a
à la fois la loi sapin 2 qui met en
place et qui impose une hauteur de
dénonciation graduée on doit dénoncer
auprès de son employeur après si ça
marche pas on peut dénoncer auprès de la
justice après éventuellement auprès des
médias la loi sapin de on à la loi
secret des affaires qui vient
immédiatement mettre
des grosses limites en expliquant que si
on dénonce un secret qui a une valeur
commerciale on risque de payer
l'intégralité du dommage causé donc
d'imaginer les montants astronomiques et
ça représente alors qu est ce qu une
information ayant une valeur commerciale
j'en sais rien en tant que juriste on va
voir ce que disent les juges dans sa
déjà donc on arrive avec une épée de
damoclès énorme et puis vous avez par
exemple l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale qui impose à tous tout
fonctionnaire ou tout officier où tout
est lui de dénoncer le procureur en cas
de connaissance de crime ou délit sans
forcément passer par la dénonciation
graduée imposée par la loi sapin de donc
aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué de
savoir finalement lorsque vous êtes
lanceurs d'alerté très complète alors ce
que vous devez faire parce que c'est
fait à dessein ou c'est fait par des
braquages je sais pas morceau tout cas
non mais je crois qu'il ya eu des lois
qui ont été fait de manière séparée que
personne n'a pensé à harmoniser et le
gros gros gros
aussi du dispositif c'est que la loi
avait avait permis la loi une loi qui
avait été votée d'ailleurs en même temps
que la loi sapin de avait avait permis
au défenseur des droits de soutenir
financièrement les lanceurs d'alerté ce
qui était une énorme avancée parce
qu'aujourd'hui le problème du lanceur
d'alert c'est qu'un il est viré il
faut qu'ils pour qui ce qui qui se loge
qui saperait il poursuivi il est
poursuivi donc il doit payer les frais
d'avocats qui sont colossaux parce que
généralement quand il est attaqué par
des grandes entreprises ses surnoms
plusieurs pays ça s'est tout de suite
plusieurs centaines de milles au très
très vite donc il doit arriver à se
nourrir et payer les frais d'avocat et
on avait réussi à faire passer cette
idée donc le défenseur des droits vous
pouvez aider financièrement leurs
alertes ces dispositions ont été
censurées par le conseil constitutionnel
donc aujourd'hui l'état ne soutient pas
financièrement ne peut pas soutenir
financièrement les lanceurs d'alerté
alors anticorps avec d'autres
associations comme transparente si et
c'est passionnant voilà on a on a créé
ce qu'on appelle la maison des lanceurs
d'alert qui a justement vocation non
seulement soutenir juridiquement les
lanceurs d'alerté mais les aider
financièrement avec un fond donc ça
c'est très récent ça fait quelques
semaines le volume du fonds c'est
combien alors je sais pas là on doit
être à quelques dizaines de milliers
d'euros séville vient d'être créée mais
c'est sûr que ça va pas c'est pas
satisfaisant parce que les lanceurs
d'alertés encore une fois son sont des
sommes astronomiques lorsque vous êtes
attaqué par plusieurs pays c'est donc ça
sera une solution on va dire temporaire
j'espère j'espère que l'état pourra
prendre le relais qu'on pourra changer
la constitution pour donner le pouvoir
aux défenseurs des droits d'aidé
financière mans les défenseurs de lille
les lanceurs d'alerté avec l'argent
public parce qu'il faut savoir qu'un des
éléments sur d'alert ça fait gagner
l'argent nous fait gagner argent
stéphanie gibeau nous a fait gagner 13
milliards dans ce qu'elle a dénoncés
donc on est un peu touché un radis rien
rien aux états unis il touche combien
oui ils ont une sorte de commission oui
mais c'est quand même logique au moins
je dis pas les récompensés mais leur
permette de vivre dignement s'unifier
vous allez retrouver dans une situation
financière très critique alors même
qu'elle nous fait économiser des
milliards donc au seuil il y avait un
titre intéressant dans libération je
crois c'était lanceur d'alert piège à
conviction c'est tout à fait ça à
circuler on a des gens courageux qui se
disent bon j'ai une battre pour
l'intérêt général et puis jour au
lendemain ils se retrouvent ruinés fait
des exemples je sais pas si on en fait
des oui en tout cas oui ça dissuade
peut-être les autres puisque on sait que
personne va vous aider donc nous on a
ici avec les maisons des lanceurs
dallaire pour essayer d aider un peu
mais je sais pas si on arrivera à aider
tout le monde est et si l'argent suffira
mais c'est quand même absolument pas
satisfaisant on n'a pas pris la mesure
de l'intérêt des lanceurs des leurs qui
sont les héros des temps modernes tout
simplement c'est pathétique non oui
c'est dommage parce que vous savez des
gens courageux il a pas tant que ça déjà
donc c'est vrai qu'il faudrait que quand
ça arrive les aider les soutenir et pas
laisser se débrouiller question internet
anti corps at il subi ou assister à des
freins judiciaire sur des affaires de
corruption
oui
oui [rires]
et plaint que plusieurs fois on subit
des manoeuvres dilatoires part
on va faire ferrand à quelques jours de
la mise en examen de monsieur ferrand il
a obtenu le dépaysement de son affaire à
lille voilà donc il ya des salles et la
france n'est pas le paradis des
manoeuvres dilatoires donc pouvez
toujours trouver quelque chose qui vous
permettent de gagner du temps etc puis
oui après on a les procureurs qui sont
pas très toujours très très courageux
vous savoir qu'un procureur n'est pas un
magistrat indépendant procureur est
nommé promu sanctionné par le ministre
de la justice et même quelque chose que
les gens ne connaissent pas mais ça paie
la remontée d'informations ça c'est
extraordinaire c'est en fait le tout les
procureurs de france doivent remonter
les informations sur les affaires
sensibles aux mini la justice vous avez
imaginé le pouvoir du ministre de la
justice qui a toutes les informations
sensibles de toutes les affaires en
france
comme le vatican non je sais pas enfin
moi je trouve ça très étonnant que voilà
on est ce type de officiel c'est ce que
je vous dis c'est pas une invention
c'est dans les circulaires on est sept
remontées d'informations qui bénéficie
donc aux mises justice et donc par
extension pouvoir en place qui va
évidemment tout savoir de tout le monde
c'est étonnant le pouvoir des lobbies on
en parle c'est une question très
importante
d'ailleurs dans le programme de monsieur
macron il était prévu encadré et lobbys
donc là c'est une grande déception de de
la loi de moralisation parce que ses
effectifs effectivement une question
essentielle parce que les lobbies ont
parasité la loi donc on se retrouve avec
des lois pas adapté on dit comment ça
s'est passé comment donner il ya un
lobby sont passés par là qu'il ya
plusieurs problèmes problème c'est que
les lobbys vont aujourd'hui peuvent
rencontrer n'importe quel parlementaire
de près dans n'importe quelles
conditions et surtout des conditions
d'opacité des tête à tête par exemple
nous mêmes anticorps on nous sommes un
groupe d'intérêts on est déclarée auprès
la haute autorité comme un groupe
d'intérêts mais lorsqu'on est reçu par
les sénateurs ou les députés dans ça
arrive on y va d'ailleurs ces publics
c'est même parfois filmées voilà c'est
tout et officiels nous mêmes on remet
notre argumentaire
en ligne comme ça tout le monde peut
voir ce qu'on a écrit est ce qu'on a dit
donc c'est complètement transparent les
lobbys les lobbys en tout cas ces
entreprises privées c'est très opaque cd
tête à tête donc c'est pas trop ce qui
se dit on sait pas trop où on connaît
pas leurs arguments et imaginez ils
peuvent de mai donner des cadeaux c'est
complètement fou c'est prévu dans le
code de déontologie et députés des
sénateurs ils ont le droit d'accepter
des cadeaux jusqu'à hauteur de combien
alors il n'y a pas de plafond c'est ça
qui est étonnant à partir de 150 euros
ils doivent le parlementaire qui reçoit
un cadeau de plus de 150 euros alors je
sais pas déjà je ne sais pas comment il
sait que ça coûte 150 euros puisque
c'est un cadeau pour maman mais
lorsqu'il pense que ça coûte plus de 150
euros il doit le déclarer au déontologue
vous imaginez bon tout ça n'est pas
évidemment public il n'y a pas de
plafond c'est complètement fou il peut
accepter voyage c'est prévu dans le code
de déontologie c'est quand il fait ce
coude abbas sont les sénateurs et
députés qui ont fait le code le même
d'ailleurs enfin les mêmes dispositions
mais c'est très étonnant un
fonctionnaire n'a pas le droit en france
d'accepter un euro ii reçoit un cadeau
ce qui est logique ça porte à sa porte
atteinte à son impartialité mais celui
qui fait la loi en france et la droite
complètement fou est en fait un
troisième problème on a aujourd'hui
beaucoup de parlementaires qui relaie
des amendements clés en main fait par
des lobbys sans le dire alors bien sûr
le glee phosphate on avait soixante
soixante amendements identiques à la
virgule près proposé par quatre groupes
politiques différents qu'elle ne me
marre je sais plus les principaux je
crois je pas voudrait le public en
marche oui oui enfin il y avait les
principaux et je crois que je parle vous
les citez m'en faire c'était cas des
composites différents et pourquoi pas je
veux dire non n'est pas contre le fait
que un parlementaire relais une
proposition proposé par un groupe
d'intérêts etc mais qu'il le dise qu'on
sache attention cette proposition elle
est proposée par tels groupes
d'intérêts à la con qu'on sache qu'une
transparence ce qu'on appelle nous
l'empreinte normative il faut savoir
d'où vient la proposition pour qu'on
puisse l'évaluer évidemment si c'est une
proposition d'un parlementaire c'est une
chose si une proposition qui viendra
comme l'intéressent et se méfient un peu
plus c'est logique donc il faut
transparence folle
vous êtes optimiste pour l'avenir pour
changer ce système vous
battez contre des moulins et vous aimez
ça bat contre des moulins mais moi
j'observe que peut-être
pas en france mais ailleurs ça bouge
omani ça bouge printemps arabe ça a
bougé alors que tout le monde disait que
ça pouvait jamais bougé regardez ce qui
s'est passé en arménie c'est
extraordinaire car mini s'il ya bien un
pays qui normalement n'avait pas
vocation à bouger serramenti où il ya
une une corruption énorme pauvreté les
normes où les gens avaient peur parce
que si vous opposer au président qu'il
est tout puissant l'époque c'est une
sorte de mini poutine s'est y étiez
blacklisté feinte et y est ostracisé eh
bien les gens ils ont fait 25 jours de
manifs et le président il est parti et
aujourd'hui c'est l'opposition qui est
au pouvoir voilà il convient de noms
déjà 0,25 jour de manif donc si vous
voulez on dit [raclement de gorge] c'est
peut-être n'ont rien lâché
bull dans le même pas un petit flash
ball un les gens ils ont dit on n'est
plus d'accord là il était resté dix ans
il est dit bon moi je vais encore rester
quelques années on n'est plus d'accord
voilà c'est tout bon ça on évoquera si
c'est facile offrant si les gens disent
on n'est plus d'accord ça va vite se
régler il sauf que très clairement ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en france
aujourd'hui il faut constater on
constate dans les yeux les gens sont
d'accord ils réalisent balkany voilà
donc il ya une sorte de ces de la
subornation de bottes avec avec un
crédit sur les générations futures oui
bien sûr pas sans bien sûr un moment
donné c'est après moi le déluge il faut
payer bien sûr et puis surtout l'argent
est mal utilisé le problème des gens qui
se transforme en clients parce que c'est
ça le problème c'est qu'ils se rendent
pas compte qu'ils pourraient rester
digne rester électeurs est resté
citoyens et que si la ville était bien
géré il aurait droit à tout ce qu' ils
sont obligés de quémander
en faveur en fait ils ont droit on a
droit à des places de crèches par
exemple dans une ville si elle était
bien géré on n'en ai pas besoin d'aller
voir sont son sont élus pour passer au
dessus de la pile voyez donc quand ils
se rendent pas compte que finalement peu
même entretiennent le la pénurie parce
que le clientélisme fonctionne à la
pénurie
si tout le monde a une place de crèche
peut pas dire que de clientélisme donc
il faut faire une pénurie compris c'est
complètement faux mais donc celui qui se
transforme en client s'est il accepte
finalement de se dégrader et de dégrader
les finances de sa ville pourquoi
charger balkany c'est un homme bien
quand même non mais je sais pas moi j'ai
vu le rapport la cour des comptes il
semblerait quand même qu'il
a mal géré la ville en plus de ces
affaires qui vient petite maison à
marrakech budget et zou c'est un martin
il avait oublié quelques 300 une toute
petite maison de rien du tout à ça peut
arriver à n'importe qui et de fictives
mende oublié d'avoir par
ci par là on est on est bien d'accord
voilà on peut avoir des trous de mémoire
mais moi j'ai écrit plusieurs fois
président que ce soit monsieur hollande
monsieur macron pour qui monsieur
balkany soit révoqué ce qu on a le droit
aujourd'hui de répondre à droite dans la
loi c'est prévu on peut révoquer un
maire qui aurait perdu son autorité
morale moi j'estime que monsieur balkany
a perdu son autorité morale et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on le laisse
encore en circulation alors que un
président la république peut révoquer un
élu pour disparition
de l'autorité morale donc je ne manque
qu'une acceptation globale encore une
fois des citoyens des basques huilé des
dossiers sur certaines personnes je sais
pas mais je pense qu'à un moment donné
on se rend pas compte de la de bouddha
voir les gens disent voilà tous pourris
parce qu'on a des gens comme ça qui
passe à la télé là encore là sur les
gilet jaune j'ai vu que monsieur balkany
avait été donné son avis donc c'est
quand même intéressant de
nous parler des impositions trop élevé
lorsqu'on fraude de les imposer de
provoc je sais pas ça on est on est sur
la quatrième dimension des
gens comme ça qui vont voilà qui vont
s'exprimer dans les médias nous
expliquer comment devrait faire ça mais
en fait les premiers responsables c qui
sait nous ont fait non on est dans une
démocratie on est tous responsables
il faut pas se contenter de montrer du
doigt les lieux en 10 ans tous pourris
il ya les élus bien sûr qu'ils ont un
pouvoir qui peuvent agile il ya les
militants dans les partis politiques qui
est pas obligé tout le temps d'avaler
les couleuvres vous avez les
fonctionnaires la police les magistrats
aussi qu'ils peuvent prendre la
responsabilité vous avez les citoyens
les entreprises qui vont parce que dans
un pacte de corruption il ya un
corrupteur et corrompu donc les
entreprises qui vont participer à des
packs de corruption et les citoyens qui
vont les réclamer des faveurs ou des
passe droits à leurs élus donc on est
tous responsables
dans une société donc il faut qu'on
prenne conscience que c'est pas une
bonne bonne organisation
effectivement on creuse la dette on a
des services publics de moins bonne
qualité on est tous responsables de
l'aco on est tous victimes on est tous à
la fois responsable aussi victime de la
corruption la fraude fiscale on a tous
payer plus d'impôts qu'on ne devrait on
aura tous des services publics moins
bonne qualité et on aura des prestations
sociales - donc il faut il faut casser
cette cercle vicieux et que l'argent
soit bien utilisé ce qui est quand même
ça nous semble préalable intéressant
quand même question
internet que je sais pas si je vais vous
la poser est ce que vous êtes fichés je
[rires]
ne sais pas je pense que quelques-uns
ont un dossier sur moi mais je les ai
pas expliquer votre avis est
ce que vous avez reçu des pressions
personnel vous votre famille vous
associez c'est ce qu'on a essayé de vous
faire sauter parce que vous vous pour
parler trivialement parce que vous
formule fourbure guîtres
ou la merde alors si on voulait
anticorps davantage anticorps c'est un
peu pour ça qu'on a créé c'est que ça
crée un réseau d'entre elles parce
qu'avant avant les associations comme
anti quand vous aviez des militants
anticorruption un peu isolé et anis moi
je sais ce que ça veut dire que les rues
jacques médecin leur association non et
à nice par exemple lorsque vous aviez un
militant anticorruption isolé subissez
des pressions les menaces des
représailles ou alors on essayait
d'acheter fin on a une cible quand on
est tout seul donc l'idée d'anticorps
c'était de créer un réseau pour
évidemment pour s'auto souto soutenir et
se protéger donc ça ça a bien fonctionné
ç'a bien fonctionné donc reçoit des
menaces temps en temps mais ne cultive
pas tant que ça bons numéros des
sous-entendus bon voilà c'est pas tant
que ça là où on est plus six blessés sur
les lits menace de plainte ou les plaint
d'ailleurs ces tourbillons voilà prêt
sur baillons qui vous ai mis des
plaintes ont en moyenne un paquet ans
j'ai un peu du mal à entrer diffamation
et dénonciation calomnieuse alors le
problème c'est que si vous voulez il ya
beaucoup de menaces y compris sur les
réseaux sociaux et pas forcément
beaucoup de vrais potes mais il ya des
quelques quelques serait plaint pas que
je vais pas citer parce que je veux pas
faire de promo au procédé au bâillon
parce qu'après c'est toujours un peu
infamant si vous voulez de dire on est
visé par une procédure bâillon d'autant
plus que par amp la diffamation vous
êtes mis en examen automatiquement
envoyée c'est pour çà et là pro sur
baillons souvent à les payer l'argent
public en plus donc voila moi je rends
pas publier tout ça pour ne pas faire de
promotion sur ses procédures bidon âgées
jamais été condamné a rien du tout
jusqu'à ce jour voilà -
jean-christophe ça vous convient ainsi
ajouté un petit million un million sakho
va à quoi vont vous achetez ce avec
année 10 et des gens honnêtes sont
beaucoup plus chers que les autres à
acheter bon [rires] alors dix millions
dix millions of the sea feriez quoi avec
10 millions à titre
personnel je
sais pas je donnerais anticorps passe
[rires]
qu'anticor si vous voulez fait beaucoup
avec très peu de moyens je pense que si
demain on avait beaucoup de moyens c'est
vraiment intéressant là aujourd'hui on a
un petit local on a une permanente à une
voiture de secrétaire comme décarie
combien dpi hla hla permanente elle a
payé je crois le smic on a deux
volontaires service civique et un local
voit ça va être filmé m² fait un truc
ridicule voilà donc anti corse et ça
c'est très peu de moyens et moi je rêve
d'avoir six juristes à temps plein voilà
donc hélas on pourrait on pourrait très
très très dissuasif sur sur ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui on a une cinquantaine
de procédures en cours donc c'est déjà
pas mal mais si on avait plus de moyens
on pourrait pourrait vraiment une sorte
de contre-pouvoir question d'internet
quel parti politique était la pointe sur
la lutte contre la corruption c'est
difficile à dire aucun bon moi je peux
vous dire en toute objectivité on avait
choqué les propositions à la dernière
présidentielle des candidats même
nicolas dupont aignan on est tout autre
le front national donc ça veut pas dire
que maintenant qu'on a on a comparé sans
donner de consignes de vote on a juste
mis en ligne checkez résumé les
propositions pour moraliser les petites
mains après
chacun fait ce qu il voulait donc mois
après je sais pas si c'est des gens qui
propose à son sincère ou pas seul et 3
qui avait fait le plus de propositions
c'était mélenchon
du poignant et hamon c'étaient les trois
après on que l'is vous aviez le front
national mais tous
les élus ne s'intéressent pas la même
fin tous les candidats ne s'intéressent
pas la même manière aux à ces questions
là ceux qui s'y intéressent moins
c'était qui le front national a eu son
nom il part du truc tous pourris voilà
émis aucune proposition derrière voilà
en gros leur solution c'est voter pour
nous et tout va le bonheur va régner et
c'est bon nous on pense que la question
s'est il faut mettre en place des
garanties
on a une confiance relative entre temps
les personnes il faut mettre en place
des garde-fous qui empêche les gens de
commettre des abus parce que vos débuts
peuvent être très bien après on sait
comment ça ce matin que nous nous ce
qu'on veut c'est des dispositifs qui
empêche donc tu es qui contrôlent des
sanctions ddt
dispositif préventif voilà nous de dire
votez pour moi après ça ça va bien se
passer c'est ce qui se passe dans
certains pays africains ça c'est jamais
bien passé voilà il faut encore une fois
des garanties ça s'est bien passé s'est
jamais bien passé si vous avez la france
derrière c'est ça non mais enfin je veux
dire lorsque vous il ya des certains
pays où on disait où le candidat disait
bon on va voter pour moi et il y aura
plus de corruption mais en fait il
faisait pareil parce que voilà il faut
encore une fois il faut pour mettre en
place des garanties pour éviter d'être
tentée même tenté soi même parce que
vous savez où parler d'un million
peut-être qu'effectivement n'importe
qui dans une paire de sa vie on lui
propose beaucoup d'argent on sait pas on
est prêt à monter à 2000 ou légaux ou
non il faut mettre en place des
mécanismes qui empêche je pose de se
poser la question du contrôle ceux qui
contrôlent une bonne question mais les
citoyens citoyens savez il ya des tas de
en
fait il
ya des tas de procès de d'organismes de
contrôle en france qui sont payés
d'ailleurs où les gens sont payés vous
avez la cour des comptes chambre
régionale des comptes la cnil voilà
donc après le saut sied pas déceler les
abus c'est les sanctionner moi je suis
très étonné par an en france on ait des
rapports la cour des comptes qui sont
alors nous deux chaque année vous avez
chaque fois on veut pas dire que ça
s'améliore ça chaque année ces quatre
carabines et c'est calamiteux vous avez
même parfois sur un même organisme ça ça
change pas dire que sur l'institut de
france par exemple qui en est au
troisième rapport calamiteux la cour des
comptes ça fait tous les six ans le
faire un pont ça fait 18 ans donc dans
trois ans je vous annonce on aura un
quatrième un port calamiteux
il n'y a rien qui se passe donc pourquoi
n'y a pas de suite on a on a des gens
très sérieux qui rendent des rapports
plutôt bien fait bien détaillé ya pas de
suite pas de sanction n'y a pas de
médias renommer une amélioration du
contrôle c'est très étonnant moi j'ai
saisi le parquet national financiers
dans la sphère du grand paris il ya eu
un rapport mais calamiteux en janvier la
cour des comptes qui nous dit que donc
le grand paris c'est 38 milliards un
dérapage de 13 milliards qui n'est pas
fini puisque on a encore cinq ans à
venir et on nous dit il ya 164 marque
marchés publics passés sans mise en
concurrence bon
bah je vis c'est un scandale énorme les
ministres ils vont prendre la parole ça
va être y avoir un électrochoc six mois
après il s'est rien passé donc moi je
saisis partie parquet national fiancé
mais il devrait y avoir un truc comme ça
il n'y a pas besoin d'une association
qui qui saisit par création et financier
aux imaginer que le ministre devrait
devrait demander des comptes il devrait
quand à des temps 13 milliards 13
milliards enfin c'est un truc de fou
donc là je suis très étonné on a
généralement dans les dispositifs qui
fonctionne bien mais n'y a pas de pas de
suite alors je m'explique pas si vous
les anticorps ne devrait pas hésiter on
ne devrait pas par la sphère des des
sondages de l'elysée s'est passé par ces
partis d'un rapport la cour des comptes
en 2009 qui explique sarkozy a fait des
sondages tous les côtés avec parfois des
objets qu'ils n'avaient rien à voir avec
la fonction présidentielle nous on a
porté plainte on n'a pas si trois ans
pourrait déclarer recevable trois ans
juste pour être recevable là aujourd'hui
il ya à peu près tout le monde qui est
mis en examen sauf évidemment sarkozy et
on va on va vers un procès donc on est
en 2010 8 en 8 ans bon
normalement anticorps n'aurait pas dû
intervenir on aurait dû automatiquement
avoir une procédure de signalement et
sans dire si anticor n'avait pas été là
il n'y aurait pas de pad enquête pas de
procès sur alors qu'on a un rapport de
la cour des comptes qui explique qu'ils
expliquent que s'arrête ça a été fait
sans marché qui a eu des doublons et
même des il ya même des sondages qu'on
n'a jamais retrouvé donc on pense qu'ils
étaient prestations fictives c'est
complètement fou donc nous on se bat
finalement pour qu'un jour on n'est plus
besoin de nous parce que c'est
absolument pas normal qu'on qu'on soit
obligé nous de porter plainte ou de
faire des signalements normalement assez
d'autorité en france pour que les choses
se passent normalement et sainement et
on est très étonné finalement d'avoir ce
rôle qui ne devrait pas être le nôtre
est ce que vous avez en tête pour
vous qu'il était le meilleur président
de la cour des comptes quelle est la
qualité le meilleur président de la cour
des comptes ce
gars n'était pas mal il disait des
bouchauds j -p c'est lui qui avait
théorisé là
la primeira casseroles ont rappelé il
expliquait que les gens récompensé les
illusions de casseroles et c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est toujours le cas c'est
une bonne théorie nous les français nous
le peuple on aime les gens qui ont des
casseroles ouais on les trouve sympa ils
rendent des services que rendent pas
forcément ceux qui sont honnêtes ou qui
veulent instaurer des procédures
transparentes voilà témoin moi je
rencontre souvent des électeurs qui
bizemont élus les super il m'a filé une
place de crèche un emploi pour ma fille
une subvention pour mona sauce - durée
explique que c'est pas ça un élu
normalement m'ont amené on est sur
d'autres planètes comme en afrique comme
en chine en inde aussi redemandé tout le
monde est achetée c'est très dangereux
le
casier vierge pour les politiques ça
vous intéresse oui c'est une proposition
anticorps depuis longtemps qui a
d'ailleurs été votée le 1er février 2017
à l'époque il y avait pas eu de problème
et puis la nouvelle majorité nous a dit
que ce n'était pas constitutionnelle
donc c'est très curieuse de la
république en marche oui donc
saisissent avait été voté par tout le
monde en 2010 est un an après c'est plus
constitutionnel sans que le conseil
constitionnel se prononce d'ailleurs sur
les choses donc évidemment c'est c'est
quand même la moindre des choses
effectivement qu'on ne puisse pas être
candidat leader le casier judiciaire
vierge c'est un peu simpliste nous nous
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'il faut
effectivement quelqu'un qui a été
condamné pour des atteintes à la probité
ne puisse pas être candidat si vous avez
été condamné pour pour
des choses qui n'ont rien à voir avec
une atteinte à la probité du cannabis
oui ou la diffamation enfin vous avez
des choses des fois qu'ils pouvaient
vite vous retrouver condamné sans que ça
soit vraiment donc c'est vraiment pour
nous les atteintes à la probité mais la
loi en cas avec avait été proposé et
voté en première lecture en février 2007
et est bien rédigé à ce point là c'est
pas c'est pas un casier absolument
vierge mais c'est uniquement les
intérêts probité très curieusement ça
n'est pas passé aux oubliettes alors
c'est d'autant plus dommage
que c'était une promesse du candidat
macron c'était dans son programme il
avait il s'est engagé sur le casier
judiciaire vierge l'encadrement jobbik
passé
et donc
sa c2 de promesses qu'il n'a pas tenues
et c'est dommage parce que il faut
savoir que tous les députés en marche ce
sont donc ont porté ce programme donc en
fait ils tous ceux qui ont porté ce
programme se sont dédits quelque part
qu'ils auraient que le président change
d'avis bons hommes et tous les députés
auraient dû d'y retourner et nous on a
été élus sur cette promesse là donc il
faut le faire non et on se rend bien
compte que cette pose problème quand
même d'aller devant les électeurs en
disant on va faire ça ne pas le faire et
après de dire mais c'est bizarre les
gens ne sont pas contents ils sont pas
contents parce que moment donné tu en
entends utilisent les programmes ils y
croient et ils sont un petit peu
contrariée quand on leur dit que que
vous avez quelqu'un qu'on va pas le
faire alors qu'ils ont gagné les
élections c'est un peu bizarre il faut
bien passer les grenades lacrymogènes
ont acheté quatre ans de stock mais il
faut y avait passé il ya des fraudes
dans l'armement toujours aussi dont
karachi tout cela c'est ça s'est calmé
ou des rétrocommissions des choses comme
ça annonay
dans le on a porté plainte dans la
sphère du casa guette oui c'est sûrement
des fraudes casa
gets étaient des copies terre qu'on
avait vendu en échange de
l'obtention d'une belgique
d'une libération d'une personne qui est
un ami de celui qui vend des forces
étaient six [rires]
à faire un peu comme molex aux commandes
là c'était quand même 10 milliards voilà
au brochet bon 10 milliards ça fait
combien de millions aurait [rires]
été mauvais en math mois en 1/2 ans
quand on vend des avions un canton
à sa chérie qui fait des films après
derrière c'est bien oui c'est bien mais
je sers papa je crois porter plainte ont
fait un signalement c'est très bien
qu'il y ait une enquête sur cette
affaire williams oui
c'est ça oui c'est très bien vous savez
nous on tique quand on peut pas tout
faire donc c'est très bien qu'ils aient
les associations comme sherpa qui
spécialisée dans dans la convention
internationale qui aussi prenne sa part
alors
question d'internet comme en tant que
citoyen peut-on lutter contre ces
fraudes oui
mais bien sûr mais c'est notre
responsabilité comment on fait un
citoyen savez est partie moment où on
est en démocratie il a une part de
responsabilité il faut qu'un il se forme
pour comprendre comment ça se passe
c'est passé le plus dur de se changer
bah oui ça c'est pas évident parce que
c'est compliqué c'est vrai que le
aujourd'hui et comment fonctionnent les
institutions comment les décisions se
prennent c'est compliqué enfin il faut
qu'ils se forment un minimum pour
comprendre de il faut qu'ils s'informent
parce que là aussi il ya beaucoup de
gens qui donnent leur avis sur twitter
enfin s'il s'est informé un petit peu ce
serait bien 3 il faut qu'ils
réfléchissent c'est pas mal aussi et
quand il faut qu'ils votent aussi la
lutte contre la corruption ça commence
aussi dans les urnes donc ça c'est une
responsabilité que chacun doit avoir in
a beaucoup qui par paresse ne font pas
bien que soit sa forme pas ils vont
n'importe comment ou ils votent pas et
si on avait des citoyens peut éclairer
ce serait quand même plus facile après
je vous dis chacun
peut prendre sa part on peut rejoindre
les associations on peut
on peut on
peut faire pression voilà on peut se
saisir sans élus là chacun peut à son
petit niveau mais lui qui vous filent
une place en hlm une place en crèche oui
bien sûr les élus sont sensibles à
l'opinion publique aussi regarder ce qui
s'était passé quand balkany avait reçu
l'investiture à l'unanimité du bureau
d'investiture de mains des républicains
il y avait actionné ch'ti tueur en 2016
l'unité pour être candidat aux
législatives l'opinion publique à hagen
et j'ai engueulé sur réseaux sociaux et
donc du coup le parti a l'air à retirer
l'investiture donc voilà il ya quand
même des effets lorsque l'opinion
publique s'agite le manifeste son
mécontentement il peut ya des résultats
donc c'est bien de s'exprimer à ce qui
est ce qu'il faut faire comme en chine
faire
une - rétablir la peine de mort pour les
fraudeurs non
nous on en est on en est plutôt pour ce
qui est une sanction même symbolique
puisque aujourd'hui regardez christine
lagarde elle a été con reconnu coupable
de détournement de fonds publics par
négligence un pour une somme de 400
millions ces 400 millions comme les
millions elle
a pas été il n'y a pas eu de sanctions
il est toujours dur président du fmi
donc donc nous nous ce qu'on veut c'est
au moins une petite sanction quand
quelque chose un peu symbolique 6 mai
qu'une sanction qu'on dise quand même
cette personne est coupable et les
condamner donc peine de mort c'est
excessif mais qui une confiscation des
biens non et on est on est très branché
réutilisation sociale des biens
confisqués ce qui se fait d'ailleurs en
italie dire que lorsqu on confisque eu
un bien du mans à qui on le real
réaffecte mission
sociale ou d'intérêt public comme ça la
population voit voit ce cas les effets
la lutte contre la corruption la fraude
fiscale voit donc ça permet à des
associations d'avoir des locaux etc
c'est très intéressant comme comme
dispositif s'avança révisé de la lutte
contre la corruption alors question
d'internet un avis sur ce qui se passe
au japon avec carlos ghosn oui
bah corse et à l'étranger il ya les
sanctions c'était
un ami un bol de riz ou en français on a
des procès qui dure des présomptions
d'innocence 1 mais
nous on a des procès
qui sont quand même c'est considérable
là
j'ai vu france et en espagne je crois
que le trésorier d'un parti au pouvoir
était qu'on est à 33 ans de prison pour
corruption nous nos procédures 33 ans g1
ils sont jamais condamné il meurt avant
d'être condamné à regarder dassault on a
porté plainte contre dassault on va
faire des achats doit-il dit mourad donc
on a des procès qui dure des années donc
c'est au moins encore une fois si on
avait des durées on va dire normal qu'on
est un peu l'espoir que les gens avant
de mourir passe devant le juge ce serait
bien regardez de tibéri jean tiberi a
été condamné au bout de 18 ans pour une
affaire simple de de frau de fraude
électorale va faire très simple avec que
des témoins qui étaient à charge 18
ans pour le condamné quand il était même
plus député quand il était mon ami donc
c'est des copains je sais pas mais il ya
des effectivement possibilité d'avoir
des mains vides at war comme je l'aï dit
on peut faire durer le plaisir mais pas
acceptables il faut aujourd'hui avoir
plus de moyens dans la justice et puis
dans les enquêtes et que caen et des
durées correct parce que c'est
absolument pas dissuasif aujourd'hui un
élu c'est que si celui ci se fait
coincer ça va durer lorsqu'on va le
condamner il sera même plus quoi j'ai
demandé qu'on monte un peu les questions
alors est il possible pour la france de
lutter seul et efficacement contre
l'évasion fiscale ou cela doit se faire
absolument au niveau européen ou mondial
oui bien sûr c'est une très bonne
question ça doit faire au niveau
européen et mondial on comprend bien
mais déjà on repère ça serait pas mal
parce qu on comprend bien que on peut
pas nous
instaurer un taux d'impôt sur les
sociétés à 33% si à côté le luxembourg
fait les accords secrets à -2% on
comprend bien ça sert à rien je veux
dire on négocie pas oui
[rires]
par le président la commission ces
boues oui oui bah oui robin et il nous
explique où il n'ya pas de ged média
magazines y aller il nous explique que
c'est le patrimoine du luxembourg on ne
touche pas au patrimoine et donc mais on
comprend bien que c'est pas possible
c'est pato nomme donc il faut déjà que
entre nous on arrête le n'importe quoi
j'ai donc pour moi c'est pour moi c'est
un casus belli sûr qu'on peut pas
continuer à faire l'europe avec des pays
qui trichent sert à rien je dis on est
on ne jouais
pas une partie avec des gens qui
trichent je ne pensais pas possible donc
là on est aujourd'hui on a des plusieurs
pays qui jouent pas le jeu quel pays bas
la belgique lui tout voilà donc assez
c'est pas possible déjà tu déjà quand tu
reviens landes ils entendent aussi vous
avez raison voilà il faut que déjà entre
nous en soi c'est qu'on se mette
d'accord mais entre gens sérieux il ya
un moment donné moi je suis pour qu'on
fasse des compromis mais sur cette
question assez c'est juste pas possible
ou alors on supprime l'impôt sur les
sociétés depuis ça sert à rien qu'on
comprend bien que tout le monde va aller
au luxembourg faire des accords secrets
pour éviter de payer 30% en france donc
il ya il faudrait imposer
un principe c'est ainsi qu'on impose les
profits pays par pays deux des sociétés
non pas dans le pays que la société
choisie mais partout où elle fait du
profit il faut qu'elle soit imposée il
faut supprimer les accords fiscaux
secrets qui sont certes légale mais
complètement scandaleux ils sont légales
ou à l'égal c'est de vous ça hein les
gars qui sont ils sont légales c'est
maintenant fait le plupart du temps
c'est légal parce qu'on n'a pas légiféré
on n'a pas légiférer parce qu'on savait
même pas que ça existait avant la sphère
luc slick on savait pas que les accords
secrets dans moins de 1% enfin je veux
dire c'était complètement fou puisque
l'impôt au luxembourg l'impôt sur les
sociétés est de 29% donc on pensait on
pensait que ça serait s'étaient
naïvement pensé que c'était dans ces
eaux là donc il faut au niveau européen
effectivement qu'on prenne les mesures
et au niveau mondial il ya le problème
des paradis fiscaux là aussi le cancer
démocratie aujourd'hui ce sont les
paradis fiscaux il ya une trentaine et
ses shows pareil ça sert à rien et
réguler chez nous s'il suffit d'aller
dans nos pays d'à côté pour plus rien
payer donc on comprend bien que c'est
pas tenable et s'il
ya bien le blosne eu un rôle à jouer
dans ces eaux là donc c'est très
étonnant effectivement que personne ne
soit pressé de réguler tout ça alors
qu'on est tous victimes normalement
alors peut-être que ceux qui sont pas
pressés sont pas cohérents victime qui
ils ont quelques vingtaines sans doute
un symbole qu'il ya des gens qui ont des
intérêts mais [grognement] cessons ce
sont ces sont des sommes considérables
qui s'évapore du fait de du fait de
l'évasion fiscale liga fin on fait quoi
oui mais nous on n'est pas que pour
focaliser sur les gaffes alors pour
toutes les toutes les sociétés doivent
payer là où elles font du profit point
barre il ya femme voilà sûr qu'ici on
arrive déjà à faire payer les gaffes
assez bien mais a renoncé les taxis ou
pas encore oui c'est dans les cartons
mais encore une fois nous les gars
fassent c'est pas beaucoup d'entre eux
pression ce sont des grosses sommes mais
pas beaucoup il faut que toutes les
entreprises mais parce qu'elles doivent
payer encore une fois on en est on à
qu'on n'est pas là en train d'inventer
un nouvel impôt on leur dit voilà il ya
des impôts vous payer les impôts là où
cela vous fait du profil point barre
c'est quand même paraîtrait pas très
compliqué à comprendre et l'europe
admission est évidemment énorme je vais
aussi on peut pas faire un marché commun
avec une fraude fiscale à côté c'est pas
possible c'est celle émise savait que la
fraude fiscale niveau européen c'est
1000 milliards par an 1000 milliards
dont on est sûr les sommes complètement
démente donc milliards combien de
millions voilà
ça fait beaucoup
moins arrêter
[souffle coupé] me piéger la bienvenue
[rires]
chez nous voilà la
france un paradis fiscal ou sinon ben
moi j'ai eu le sentiment qu'elle nous
donne vite quand j'ai des sentiments qu
une époque où ouvertes c'était ministre
des finances oui pour pour éviter d'être
avant d'avoir un contrôle fiscal il y
avait moyen peut-être en
donnant pour en étant donateurs de tel
ou tel parti d'avoir
moins de risques après
on
a des dispositifs en un des niches
fiscales notamment sur les journalistes
n'auront les journées c'est gentil oui
ça n'a pas lieu d'être mais sur les
l'art l'art est un objet de spéculation
aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs
complètement détaché en fait ce qui se
passe autour de l'art n'a rien n'a plus
rien à voir avec l'oeuvre d'art en
elle-même c'est aujourd'hui un outil de
spe les spéculations défiscalisation
donc il ya effectivement des niches
fiscales sur lequel il faudrait un peu
toualy t il faut qu on demande un
conseil a peut-être la famille fab usma
ils connaissent un peu le marché de la
croix baisser les je crois qu'il avait
instauré aujourd'hui c'est vrai c'est
vraiment devenir un outil de spéculation
assez incroyable toute question
d'internet
alors
je vous la formule comme ces formules et
pensez vous que la justice française est
corrompu vous inquiétez pas ça craint
rien et pensez vous que la justice
française est corrompu ou tout du moins
politisés
alors
les procureurs ne sont pas indépendants
donc ça répond la question donc ils sont
nommés par le ministre la justice donc
forcément on peut se poser toutes les
questions qu'on veut d'ailleurs une des
propositions phare d'anticorps c'est de
couper le cordon ombilical entre les
procureurs alumine la justice qu'on est
des vrais procureur enfin qu on est des
pros coeur qu'ils soient des vrais
magistrats indépendants voilà donc à
partir de là effectivement certains
peuvent être mis là pour des raisons
politiques corrompus juste pas dans la
sphère bismuth
oui il y avait visiblement un magistrat
qui essayait d'obtenir des choses à
faire vis but qui était le surnom de
nicolas sarkozy voilà il était donc il y
avait un magistrat qui avait demandé un
service à monsieur sarkozy en est
sûrement oui donc il ya des il ya des
magistrats a visiblement qui sont pas
complètement intègre donc oui mais ça
s'ils voulaient l'accord ils payèrent la
corruption partout à partir du moment où
on crée pas les conditions de contrôle
et de sanction s'instaure partout et
effectivement il faut s'intéresser à la
corruption des
magistrats donc déjà si on avait des
procureurs complètement dépendant ça
serait un bon début et puis
effectivement est-ce
que vous avez trois bouquins nous
conseiller
oui moi
j'aime bien pierre mendès france pour
une république moderne sept
ans de solitude eric halphen qui un des
fondateurs d'anticorps quelqu'un d'
absolument remarquable et puis je vous
cite et l'esprit de corruption des
récoltes qui m'ont vice-président et qui
à ce jour voilà qui est un bouquin qui
nous sert beaucoup puisque ça résume
bien finalement la situation voilà trois
bouquins intéressant aux questions
internet c'est quoi ces solutions par
exemple pour les politiques les
solutions pour les abats
et fouette un goût de remous les
pouvoirs des élus pour avoir des élus
honnêtes voulait dire arrêtez les
réélire déjà fait bien vous
savez c'est ça qui est en danger on a
dit vraiment des élus carabine et j'ai
encore calé qui l'ont vu délivrer
nos plus tôt elle s'est fait coincer
avec des lingots d'or a été réélu avec
65% des voix au premier tour enfin je
sais pas quoi faire quoi donc il dit les
élus on sait qu'il ya des problèmes
auxquels ils sont réunis en donner donc
chaque citoyen se voit
là se pose des questions sur aillent
voter parce que je suis choqué par ce
qu'ils disent tous pourris je vais pas
voter non au contraire c'est ici si vous
pensez ça allait voter pour que celui
que vous pensez qu est pourri ne soit
pas réélu ces limitations si on pèse le
pour les comptes entre aller voter et
pas est voté on vous êtes d'accord avec
moi qu'aller voter ça un peu plus utile
que de pas aller voter car il ya de
pourri enfin c'est qu'on veut de blum
fait comment si vous avez que de pourri
on vote blanc enfin au premier tour
normalement vous avez plus que le choix
on a quand même beaucoup de candidats en
france beaucoup de partis et vous savez
on a des gens vraiment intéressant comme
candidat on se rend pas compte qu'il ya
dedans qu'il partout dans toutes les
élections vous avez des gens qui croient
et des gens pas forcément dans les gros
partis mais vous faut arrêter de dire
tous pourris c'est pas vrai il ya des
dégâts des candidats ou des questions
qui ont jacky son mini dit bill tankan
jamais gagné 1 euro avec la politique
qui sont là qui se bat pendant des
années donc on a ça les anticorps remet
des pratiques aussi chaque année parce
que justement on veut pas donner le
sentiment qu'il ya que des pouilles et
la catastrophe qui a aussi des gens très
courageux il ya des journal des lanceurs
alerte il ya des élus qui se battent
dans leur coin et dont personne ne parle
pas ce que ça n'intéresse personne
d'avoir des élus courageux ouverture
donc on remet des prix pour dire
attendez il ya l'espoir parce que tant
qu'il y aura des gens qui se battront
qui font preuve de courage et de
comportements vertueux il yal'espoir ce
qu'il faut juste c'est généraliser ces
comportements y les soutenir et les le
problème on va dire des votes un peu un
peu dégage est un peu les votes
sanctions ce qui a eu d'ailleurs à la
dernière présidentielle avec aux
dernières législatives où on a les gens
ont fait un black bull est pas mal de
candidats c'est que dans le lot il ya
sans doute des pas bon mais il y avait
des bons aussi bien il y avait il y
avait il y avait des députés qui était
plutôt pas mal kiki parents pisa bel
attar par exemple qui était pas mal donc
donc il faut quand je vous dis il faut
réfléchir avant de voter voilà c'est ne
pas voter pour les élus indélicats et
soutenir les élus qui au contraire parce
qu'il n'a pas tant que ça son sont
courageux et propose des choses
intéressantes donc on est on a un rôle à
jouer bien sûr en tant que citoyen est
[soupir]
ce que vous voyez des choses à aborder
hic on n'a pas abordé voyez
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire
corruption parce que c'est protéiforme
on s'ennuie jamais parce que on se marre
non non c'est comme la lutte contre le
dopage on en découvre tous les jours
dire que même quand vous réussissez un
peu à contenir le dopage en fait on
avant des nouvelles solutions une
nouvelle méthode de dopage encore et
toujours nous on en découvre tous les
jours donc moi ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est déjà
peut-être
prêter
un peu plus d'importance à la lutte
contre la corruption cei une chose
vraiment étonnante un mois avant la
présidentielle ou un sondage ifop on a
demandé à la population quels étaient
les qualités principales que devait
avoir le futur président 65%
la population a répondu il doit être
honnête il apprécie telle amnistie pour
les pv non non mais où je
suis contre l'amnistié pour les p mais
quand vous dites petites 65% c'est à
dire qu'il ya quand même 35 % la
population en france selon un sondage
ifop donc si ça me semble sérieux
qui pense qu'avoir un prêt aurait pu les
connaître c'est pas important vous
imaginez donc on est on est on est dans
ce pays là donc il faut bien que tout le
monde comprenne que c'est important que
parce que c'est eux qui payent j'adore
c'est nous qui payons et qu' on est
victime de la corruption la fraude
fiscale encore une fois j'insiste impôts
plus cher en impôts plus élevés si
l'infirmière moins de moins de services
publics assurent social - donc on est
victime il faut absolument qu'on arrive
à faire le lien entre la fraude la
corruption et note qualité de vie et
aujourd'hui à au moins 35 % la
population qui fait pâlir donc ça c'est
très grave parce que évidemment dans les
yeux ça se ressemble et soutenez les
associations comme anti cancer anti
corner on est de 1300 adhérents pas mal
enfin on devrait être 200 me voyez moi
quand je vais négocier et que milieu
juste ici citer deux cent mille
adhérents c'est plus facile il me parce
que bon la dernière fois c'était j'étais
pas très convaincant parce que j'avais
deux mille adhérents mais voilà là aussi
ça permet aussi de peser sur 1000 s'est
passé juin sur nous on a le plus de
200000 un follower sur youtube pour
décrire décrocher une interview du
partant luke et danser c'est très
compliqué oui bah enfin deux sens mais
c'est un début mais on voit bien enfin
il ya quand même les signaux qui font
qu'il est contre la corruption fraude
fiscale n'est pas l'obsession de tout le
monde et encore une fois c'est dommage
parce qu'on est la solution est là
lorsqu'on
à 2000 milliards de dettes il 100
milliards de déficit chaque année
l'argent
on prend où on va pas augmenter les
impôts on a bien compris je crois
maintenant avec les gilet jaune peut
plus augmenter on peut toujours baisser
la qualité service public enfin déjà ils
sont quand même assez bien dégradé les
prestations sociales encore non non mais
encore non mais enfin je trouve que ça
se dégrade pas mal vous avez fait un
petit séjour aux urgences ce n'est pas
très longtemps la santé la sécurité la
propreté ça c'est grave voyez
comme on l'avenir de la france
économique
non un jean moi
je pense qu'on est un pays qui a un gros
potentiel et qu'il faut en donner qu'on
ait conscience de ça et que on est on
comprenne qu'on mérite mieux tout
simplement un potentiel comme un jeu
pour faire quoi ils you on a payé très
créatif en un pays riche parce que on a
l'impression qu'on est pauvre mais pas
du tout d'un pays riche oui d'ailleurs
les riches sont de plus en plus riches
et les pauvres de plus en plus haut donc
il faut mieux répartir la richesse pour
l'intérêt de tous et dans
beaucoup de choses à faire et encore une
fois on a des grosses marges de
manoeuvre sur fraude
fiscale corruption gaspillage d'argent
public on n'a pas beaucoup parlé mais on
s'intéresse aussi beaucoup à cette
question vous savez qu'en france on a
créé une catégorie qui s'appelle et les
grands projets inutiles et est imposé il
m'a peu près une centaine le dernier
c'est notre dame des landes et tout le
monde trouve ça normal on gaspille des
millions des milliards personne ne va en
prison après personne rendez compte on
paye et je vais faire ce qu'on aime en
démence et l'argent public donc il faut
aussi faire attention à mieux
contrôler nos ce qu'on appelle les
grands projets que des experts
indépendants qui les procédures
démocratiques on arrête de prendre les
décisions complètement hallucinante qui
va coûter des millions voire des
milliards donc on est un gaspillage
d'argent qu'on vous dit on à gros
potentiel se dire on a une grosse marge
de manoeuvre on a si on arrêtait de
gaspiller tout cet argent et ne laisser
passer des fraudes massives nourri
beaucoup d'argent pour faire des choses
un peu plus intéressantes comme
l'éducation ducation bien sûr
l'éducation
beaucoup d'argent c'est la crise quand
même maintenant on peut se les gèle les
quartiers la vie des quartiers et
banlieues aurait injecté des sommes
énormes qu'il faut l'argent il faut
prendre quelques parts et cet argent il
me manque parce que on va pas le
chercher là où il devrait ou là on
devrait s que vous avez un conseil pour
les jeunes générations bouteille
à la mer quelque chose d'impérissables
sur internet écouter gandhi
disait montrer
l'exemple n'est pas le meilleur moyen de
convaincre c'est le seul dont je crois à
chacun d'entre nous d'être exemplaire
d'être à la hauteur des
valeurs de notre pays est à la hauteur
des générations futures parce que nos
enfants vous demander des comptes un
jour ou l'autre un canton va leur donner
le pays dans un sale état ils vous
diront mais vous avez fait quoi soyons à
la hauteur et et qu'on ait des choses
intelligentes allant répondre quand ils
nous posons la question la montre
l'exemple jean christophe picard merci
merci à vous
[musique]